[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 167 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Mandel and I'm here with my
colleague the wonderful Gabby Ferrara
how you doing today Gabby good I like
the wonderful how are you I'm doing
pretty well who do we have joining us
today we have today a murukku eval she
will be talking a bit about number pi if
you've seen like any of the news
recently its kind of gone everywhere
which is awesome so Emma's gonna talk
about how she broke the world record for
pot which is pretty amazing
after we finish with Emma I'm gonna be
asking mark the question of the week how
do I track what is happening to my
containers who has access to them
changes and so on and so on
but like always why don't we start with
our cool things of the week let's go
yeah I'm gonna go first okay the first
cool thing of the week the website has
gone live for next on air so as probably
many of you know the flagship event for
Google Cloud Club next is coming up but
if you're unable to attend in San
Francisco there is a live stream that
you can watch next on air it's actually
pretty cool the web sites live we'll
have it in the show notes but it has
multiple channels there's a live stream
so you can see like the exhibitions you
can see particular breakout they'll be
exclusive content customized programming
also so good stuff probably also worth
noting is that if you're interested you
could also organize a next extended
event so if you want to bring your local
community together and basically watch
the live stream together and do awesome
things read the guide you have a look at
the becoming a host all the details
they're in there already are a few set
up so you can also check out the map
that shows you where next extended
events are happening so if you want to
check those out or attend any of them
you can see which ones are local so make
sure to check out that I think it's
going to be really cool if you aren't
gonna be there in person here in San
Francisco but another cool thing is if
you are gonna be there in San Francisco
for next you can get cloud certified and
we are gonna be making available six
called certifying exams to be taking a
next on site so there is a link on the
blog to see what you need to know to be
able to do the exam fantastic we're
gonna do a shout out to our friends over
at Google
they're pushing out a few new releases
with the GDC well GDC will be right now
actually but they're adding some new
features so if you wanted to have
gameplay data that was based on say
Google Maps pathfinding and routing
algorithms you'll have access to that
now they also have interesting
information about biome data so
basically what kind of environment
you're in like a desert or a grassland
or things like that
they're also exposing elevation
information as well so whether you know
you can go up and down like the height
of where you are at that kind of stuff
so if you want to learn more I will put
a link in the show notes but if you're
gonna be at Game Developers Conference
which is literally right now make sure
to come to the Google booth and check it
out and talk to all the people there now
a trip to memory land and nostalgia for
the 90 days I'm so excited you have a
mission Google Earth just released the
game within the app where you can try to
catch Carmen Sandiego and you go around
the world to find the jewelry that was
stolen by Carmen so this is actually the
first game and it's gonna be a series of
games so you just need to keep an eye
for it literally an iframe I'm so
excited I need to play this very badly
this is literally my photo you just said
your age well I tell you what why don't
we go chat to Emma and hear about all
the amazing things she's doing with Pi
let's go like - no talk to him I'm very
impressed let's do it so it is an
exquisite pleasure to have Emma Haruka
allow joining us today fellow developer
advocate are you doing Emma I'm good
thank you for having me today yeah
thanks for coming to join us in the in
the podcast booth we're gonna talk about
pi day today but before we do that why
don't you tell us a little bit about who
you are and what do you do here at
Google
sure I'm deaf advocate with the Google
cloud platform so on the same team as
Gavin mark I was working in Tokyo until
December and I just moved to Seattle so
I'm one of you
welcome welcome thank you my work is
usually around computing products like
virtual machines storage network these
are subtle products and technologies
know like containers machine learning
something like everything you think of
when you hear the word
well so Emma what is pi tell us what is
pi for the layman or a woman in this
podcast sure pi is the constant of the
ratio so I can read this a circus second
fairness to its diameter so usually you
use three point one four one it goes on
like this you you probably how many
numbers of Pi can you remember so I can
do in Japanese better something goe G Q
it's like usually four yeah it's been
more than I can remember
I'd like 3.14 and that's it that's your
approximation yes yeah that's what a
calculator the for so what would I use
PI for what's this implication it's
everywhere right so whenever you see a
circle on your computer they use pi and
if you want to play a game and usually
you have some kind of UI part of those
sucker
right when you launch a rocket they use
a pie to calculate their trajectory it's
everywhere
so how do you calculate pi good question
I used Y cruncher that is a program
developer X on the e so I just design
the class so in Google cloud run the
program for four months and here I got
the results did you say you design a
cluster yes the amount of data didn't
fit on a single machine so I had to use
25 machines and it takes a little time
like four months
Wow four months
yes how many how many numbers of Pi did
you calculate for thirty-one 308 it's
and a little bit so it goes like three
one four one's exactly like the sequence
of pi oh that's nice so step us through
this sir there's a particular algorithm
that you use for calculating PI and
there was an existing program for that
yes exactly
cool and then you distributed that
across multiple machines is that right
not technically so the program doesn't
work in a distributed manner and Pi is
fundamentally difficult to like for
power and computing it doesn't work well
and so here's a problem on Google cloud
platform
you can attach up to 64 terabytes of
storage to a single virtual machine
right and in order to calculate 31 300
is 2 pi you'd need more than 170
terabytes of disk and you know to mount
that a month straight I had to run 24
storage nodes and that has them remotely
open back to the network so I had to use
25 machines so you use 24 machines but
how did you go from one digit to another
it's not made to work distributed how
did you get to link one thing to another
sure so the computation the main program
run only one of the machines and the
others machines were just switched their
literary disks NFS so you just mount
these disks on the main node and you
just store the data so the calculation
the algorithm itself wasn't distributed
at war and we use iced coffee instead of
a regular NFS protocol because ice
clergy suit better for random access and
we needed lower latency more bandwidth
for a lot of random reads and writes
so you made thirty one point four
trillion and a little bit apparently
just let me know that why that number
the previous world record was around
twenty to twenty sheets and I wanted to
make it significant I could do like 23
digits but it'll be like oh you just did
it to break the world record
mm-hmm and I want you to make it similar
to panic a meaningful a little bit by
making the sequence exactly the same as
pi pi goes on like three one four so the
actual number of digits goes like three
1.4 trillion digits is this all of Pi
no PI continues infinitely so you'll
never get the entire digits it's a
rational number there's no end so why
did you do that EEMA why did you decided
to break the world record because it
sounded cool it's a good reason yeah I
have a long story here basically when I
was a kid like 11 years old I learned
about
and soccer in school probably and at
that time I had access to some BBS not
the internet before the Internet and I
was able to download a program to cope
with PI so I could do something on a
computer that I learned at school so it
was cool and I wanted to actually
calculate more digits I knew so the
program had the text about the current
world record and was I think billions of
digits or something
oh yeah and I wanted more digits but I
couldn't I was sure about math I had no
idea how these are things worked so I
had to wait and computing resources
either I had no access to supercomputers
because I was an ordinary kid and I just
started creating 22 divided by 7 is a
good approximation of pi but it took
awhile to realize it was not actually
true value of pi my math teacher told me
the approximation and I wrote a program
that's what my first program that I
wrote in C and I was cheated how much
disk space did you end up actually using
when you calculated PI to 3.4 plus a
little bit I'm just gonna keep saying
that trillion digits how much disk space
did you actually end up using out so for
the temporary workspace it used about
100 's and to store the digits you'd
need about 30 terabytes because each
digit it is a byte doesn't make sense
and is this data set available to use
can other people play with it
yes sure also we have the digits
available via HTTP so you can actually
download the digits entirely from google
cloud or it takes a little time like to
download it is only if I just want to
play with it you can launch a virtual
machine on Google cloud and copy
snapshots of the digits I'll put a link
somewhere to put in the channels yeah
yeah so it's really easy so we have
snapshots of the disks images you just
need to copy it it takes you 10 minutes
to copy the digit like 30 terabytes of
data and we make the digits as a disk
for your washing machines and
just need to mount it from your smart
machine if you're running Linux you just
need to run a mount command if you're
running winners you need to open the
control panel and Marty it so you said
that it took four months to calculate it
all how much did that actually cost
that's a good question
I don't know precisely I use a Google
project share with other people so I
don't have access to the exact number
but I did some math and it's wrong
$200,000 that's fine yeah it's fine it's
fine
that's cheap it is cheap if you build a
computer like buying platform like
hardware stores and eBay and stuff it
could probably build a computer that can
target 31 three unities of pie in four
months for tens of thousand dollars so
if you build a computer it be having
much much cheaper yeah but it's a
trainer with the phone it's a trade-off
with some cloud so you have redundancy
you have all that kind of stuff so it's
just not the storage you know exactly so
if you run this calculation on your
computer like a physical computer you'd
have to take care of these failures
because hard drives break even SSDs
break so you probably need to place
disks couple times during your
calculation if your disk fails you need
to stop the calculation and replace this
can we start the allocation from a
checkpoint you'll lose some time for
that and backups and restoring is much
harder on physical housing because if
you're running the program and cloud you
just need to take snapshots Oviatt disks
so that that's easy you even don't have
to stop your program but with physical
Hardware because hard drivers are not
designed for simultaneous iOS you need
to stop the program copy the data to
other disks and restart the program so
it's much harder on physical holloway
gonna ask did you actually have any
failures during the four months or did
you just keep running from Holly at some
point we had no lost failures or
interruptions but during the hour
experiments when there's live migration
because on Google cloud when there's
something like maintenance or software
upgrades on the host side we live
migrate washing machines the another
host and nine migrations usually takes
tens of milliseconds if you're running a
web application on that but for PI
calculation it takes as long as 15
minutes whoa
so diamond works in this way the program
starts to copy memory regions and disk
to a new host and it usually doesn't
impact your compute calculation and then
when the program thinks they copied most
of the memory regions because you never
catch up it stops the virtual machine
copy the rest of the memory regions and
we study computing on the new node but
Pike program works in a way that it
literally rewrites every memory on the
washing machine so memory bandwidth is
faster than network bandwidth in most
environment so the live migration
program never catches up memory copies
so it needs to stop a little bit longer
like usually a minute and then it
restarts the calculation but it still
needs to copy the rest of memory from
the other machine to the new machine so
the slows down the cognition for 15
minutes because we used a scotchy to
mount remote disks there is a timeout
value for ice ecology and the default
value is around 10 seconds to 50 seconds
that's usually enough on any network
switch but we had to increase the value
to 50 minutes got it but once you
increase the value is nice and there are
small software's
large-scale competing is hard yes I was
gonna say like Blake stuff breaks like
wheel breaks and usually memory disks
protected by checksums or ECC's or some
kind of error detection and correction
mechanisms but we read and wrote run
tempered by swaddle over the four months
and there are two occasions that the
data was cropped
silently and why cruncher the program
detected a corruption I don't know
well good that program detected it yeah
so in that case can the white cruncher
pick up where it left off or do you have
to start that's good yeah I have a
curiosity it doesn't like a double right
you're like one to save to disk and one
to a saving point or how does it work
like it has saving points every hundred
digits or something like that
sure so what culture saves checkpoints
so checkpoints are internal structure of
its mach memory so it flushes its
internal structure to the disk
occasionally maybe twice a day or once a
week depending on the progress of
calculation and pi is calculated in a
way that you need to store actually all
the digits you're working on at any
point of the creation it doesn't work
like you calculate the first four digits
and then store data and continue the
next hundred digits or something like
that you need to decide how many days
are you going to calculate it like
before you begin and move on you mention
how much disk space you're using how
much memory was in there so I used one
of the biggest virtual machines with one
point four terabytes of memory how much
of that did you actually end up using
like a lot of it
99% I just left 20 gigabytes or
something for extra like just in case
how many horse 96 cores vcp is its own
the ante on skylake processor so there
are a couple of virtual machines like
issues from one is the N 1 megohm in 94
that's the machine I used with correct
process and I need scores one point from
Foot Terrace memory the other choice was
in one suit remem 160 with photo as
memory and like one horse well but it is
poor word processor window and it
doesn't support avx-512 which would see
we can speed up the calculation and what
cruncher doesn't work very well with
Numa the Numa is architecture where you
have multiple processors memories
attached to each of the processors so
they have non-uniform access that
latency and bandwidth to each region on
the memory so the more cores you have
the more complex and slower the memory
access would be so actually adding more
cores might have slowed down the
location so I decided to go with the two
socket system we avx-512 support avx-512
these and accelerated instructions by
Intel so it processes 512 bits of data
in one clock so it's much faster than a
wiggler of floating-point operations I
never thought like actually changing the
number of course would actually make
them access to memory slower
that's a Cohen teresting best case to
show up like how that can influence
proportional inversed situation that's
totally cool yeah totally it's not an
intuitive reasoning so for large-scale
computing or mathematical simulations
memory bandwidth is one of the important
factors to determine hardware and
algorithms and recent computers are
really constrained by memory bandwidth
so you can't actually feed the CPU with
enough data that you need so CPUs are
much much faster usually more than ten
times faster than the main memory and
storage is much slower than memory so in
order to keep CPUs busy you need to
design memory architecture and memory
access patterns carefully that's really
interesting what was probably the most
surprising realization you had when you
were building this stuff it was much
harder than I thought so in the first
place before actually doing that project
I thought it would be not easy but not
too hard because you have cloud
everything is redundant and protected by
different layers of software so usually
you don't have to worry about single
disk failures or anything like that
so I thought I don't have to stop the
calculation or like I wouldn't have to
worry about these carriers anything like
that but there was live migrations and
it did affect
migrations and mounting 64 terabytes of
storage require some kind of design and
trying errors and why cruncher has some
tunable parameters so you can control
the disk i/o size block size of these
tiles for hard drives you don't want to
write data by a small chunk like for Q
bytes or something you usually want to
write in big blocks of megabytes but
with SSD I used SSD for the project a
city cities are much better with random
access and smaller access so I had to
run some benchmark to determine the best
block size for disk access thank you
so I remember when I was school and I
had to calculate the exponential and
that was hard because I could only do it
for so long because of the memory
allocation that kind of stuff so doing
math in a regular computer is really
hard because you don't have enough
resources to do so what the common
person should look for if they want to
try to do more advanced math like you
did sure
so there is a website called from alpha
that's a free web service there is a pro
subscription you probably want to pay
for it but we come out for you only need
to enter any algorithm or equation
formulas and powerful will solve that
equation for you so you can render grass
and rock charts access solve occasions
it's really convenient I usually use it
to start with any like new equations or
like mathematical program so usually
even use a calculator or computer
you only get approximations if you put
1/3 1/3 you'd never get the true value
of 1/3
but with my offer it treats the rational
number as it is so you usually get the 2
value of a formula so that's really
convenient if you wanna play more with
math why cruncher has a feature called
custom constants so you actually enter
the formula you want to calculate and
why crunch 100 arrests so you can
calculate for example 1 divided by
square root or something something like
that
with Y cruncher and
somewhere in between we have
collaboratory which is a hosted version
Jupiter Jupiter notebook is a Python
program that you can interactively run
Python or any other programs so there
are a couple of services where you can
use Jupiter notebook cargo is one of
them collaboratory is one of them so you
just need your login you can try
different math problems or machine
learning program that's it's really easy
yeah I use it all the time before we
finish up mr is there anything you want
to make sure you get on the podcast or
anything cool that you're up to in the
near future that you want people to come
say hi to you at so we are planning a
talk on this project that next 19 in San
Francisco that's in April I don't think
we have free tickets I don't think we
have free tickets now but if you happen
to be at next 19 please come to your
talk will invite Alexander the actual
developer why cruncher oh yeah
next so it's let me exciting his program
was used to co-create break the wall
recall of five times before recall so
it's really a popular program marker
probably gonna leave you at the booth
and go straight to Amos talk that seems
fair that's reasonable I don't I don't
blame you mm-hm that seemed certainly
fair well Emma thank you so much for
joining us today on the plug us and
talking to us all about pie and math and
doing really crazy stuff on the cloud
Thank You Emma thank you so much for
having me so Thank You Emma for coming
and talking to us and now we're gonna
ask Marc the question of the week again
so how do I track what is happening to
my containers and who has access to them
changes etc yeah that's a really good
question if people aren't aware on
Google cloud there is a thing called
cloud audit logging cloud order logging
is essentially set up to answer that
questions of like who did what where and
when and that's the thing and part of
cloud audit logging is being able to do
audit logging on your containers as well
so by default container analysis audit
logging is set up for admin activity so
basically anything in admin that would
do to any of your containers but for
example
analysis riots and things like that and
reads are not necessarily set up by
default but you can set those up so if
you go into your cloud console and you
go into configuring data access logs
you're able to configure exactly what it
is that you want to track with your
audit logs regarding to your containers
may be other audit logs as well so you
can see exactly what's going on inside
your system if you want to track certain
security things or maybe just see what's
actually happening or maybe even debug a
problem so super super handy things so
that if you ever need to see who does
what where and when to your containers
you are able to do so so george orwell
excellent before we finish up Gaby what
are you up to what are you doing I'm
doing a lot of stuff I am going to be on
call max 2019 that's gonna be awesome
nice I'll be doing my taxes right after
that and the weekend after I call next
and before all of that I'm doing a
webinar a migrating to called Seco on
the Google website the link is on the
blog yes awesome
so when this comes out it'll be
wednesday at Game Developers Conference
so which point actually the Google booth
will be open I'll probably floating
through there a lot I will be presenting
at at the conference on Wednesday I'll
be doing a booth talk talking about open
sourcing game development I was a
Thursday afternoon check the booth for
details I'll be floating around to my
whole systems of Game Developers
Conference is huge I'll also be a cloud
next as Gabby will be as well doing
podcasting stuff and giving a talk on a
ganas and all the other good things I'll
be East Coast game conference in Raleigh
North Carolina or shortly thereafter
talking about okones and again open
source net salsa and then finally I'm
also going to be at i/o doing some fun
stuff as well too so if you're gonna be
at i/o make sure to come and say hello
nine different I go to i/o I'm jealous
yeah I've been tired in a while actually
I'm pretty excited thank you awesome
well yeah Gabby thank you so much for
joining me on the podcast this week
thank you Mark have a nice to meet ya
and thank you all for listening and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]